hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the curse of
Blackwater now we're back at the main
menu because I've got a strategy for
which and I've got something called my
throat but it's kind of making my voice
sound a little more awesome right now so
I'm gonna leave it there and not clear
my throat at all so let's get into it I
hope that the bug that didn't happen
before is not gonna happen again ever
I've not been huh okay now that's gone
alright sorry who's like in the middle
of a tickle turn oh my god
okay I don't know what that was just
some something cutting my throat so
we're gonna have to go back out do level
AK and then do a manually alright so
anyway my strategy is my strategy is I'm
gonna go laugh this time like I did the
first time on through because I need to
get that key that unlocks a door which
unlocks the crowbar I think to get to
the other thing my mission active
automatic allows you to get the world
hopefully the door will keep the
monstrosity bay
well it won't we all know that here we
go we shall continue for it okay let's
go come on we have no time to waste
gotta go in this room first check the
cabinet get some batteries if I can
which I cannot batteries be a thérèse
key there is oh wait a minute that was
wait that's chemical key storage number
two which is the warhead frack okay
that'd be a good hiding place that's
chemical key storage number two which
was the one that I was missing the last
time I went so that's not the key that I
was looking for before look that's
really good to have all right I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna do it to it I'm gonna
do it real good see looking for
storeroom need to meet that don't know
why oh yeah here's the key that was the
office storage key so this is the office
storage key which is gonna help me
because it's going to give me and the
batteries I can't carry
I know more bears I just got to be very
very very careful about what I do and
how I do it okay is there any
aha another switch okay cool
okay I hear him sounds like he's right
outside the door it's almost as if he's
programmed to hang around where your are
OOP
can't hear him again okay don't come in
here bro that's right yeah bash down
that door I'm over there oh you almost
got me oh no I'm just I'm tied up in a
corner naked just come on what
they're tiny
alright whatever Frigga vrak I can't win
can't win just gonna win
hiding apparently in a place is not a
good idea so I'm just gonna grab this
key get out of here there's no nothing
maybe there's something but I don't know
don't care it's gonna look for bad
batteries yeah wait
it's a mill no it was not okay I'm
wasting time wasting time and effort I
need to be moving forward to be able to
do these things that I want to do I need
to get in there get this thing over here
flip the switch get over and then move
on to the next area why why did he come
for me I do not know bad we nope okay so
this is really really really difficult
actually
this is surprise elf fudge nutters you
didn't see a thing
you didn't got anything okay where you
at where you at
white door okay you're over there
close this door move over to the next
area got two keys and I threw a switch
which means that I'm in much better
situation than I was before
okay nothing here okay one light is on
need to find other things that I need
but I've already forgotten what is where
on this area keys chemical storage
number war now right all right all right
all right all right let's do this those
two any all rights I'm not doing so all
right give me good night skip into their
medicine okay oh he's nearby
just got to remember to close things
behind me okay that's the second switch
need to get that so I can get the
chemicals to be able to blow a hole in
the wall in the debris [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
where are you where are you revealing
yourself you're not here okay I've got
the I've got the key for that room nope
nope nope nope going this way I cannot
let him see me I do not want to be found
I'm a scared little baby okay I've got
all three chemical storage keys which
hopefully means that I will be able to
do what I need to do I hear him okay
come on come on
there's crowbar in here I believe my
battery's starting to die okay got the
crowbar alright battery I don't hear him
crap he's here oh crap oh crap I'm gonna
be stuck in this room and he's gonna
grab a chunk of meat got the chunk of
meat I don't think there's anything else
in here that I need is there
I don't remember I'll hold this door he
busted in this door for some random
reason I don't know why but he did this
is a very high-stress situation right
now
okay he's are coming got to go around
this corner cuz there's a switch here
okay so now
I don't hear him hopefully that means
he's far enough away that he's not gonna
bother me okay I hear him
okay he's somewhere else he just passed
a door open to somewhere else
don't know where don't care oh don't
come here quick quick quick quick like
like funny volatile chemical number one
oh crap oh crap oh crap where is he
where is he don't care don't care don't
care can go in here sweet all right all
right give me some chemicals come on yes
all right all right so I just need one
more chemical I'll go in the last
storage room I remember where it is oh
he's right outside gotta go gotta go
gotta go going back through here okay
I've got two chemicals I just need to
find the last chemical storage area and
then go on my merry way just faked you
out with that didn't I I got the hunk of
meat that's right I need to go to the
other side now
okay I don't hear him but I've done that
before I didn't hear him and then all
sudden he was right around the corner
yeah there is okay I'm gonna sprint all
the way down to the other side and try
to exit through there the hunk of meat
I'm guessing when I put the hunk of meat
down he's gonna come through and eat up
the hunka me and then bust down that
door that's what he's gonna do
that's what he's got it doe oh crap how
does he go down here so quickly
this [ __ ] ball pick load up bull
where is he
where I don't see him
okay I hear him he's like right behind
that door
where is he where is he
sure okay go go go go go go go go go go
go
do ya I'm pretty sure that he can hear
me when I'm running so that's how he's
following me really closely but he's not
gonna get me because I'm gonna put this
meat down there Nikhil this way and hide
over here unless he comes down this way
yeah that's right smash open that door
buddy buddy buddy hmm okay there it is I
heard him smash the door don't know
where he's gonna go after that hopefully
away forever I just need this last
chemical and then I have all three right
okay
where you going are we still in that
room is he
I don't know hard to tell
okay he's not here come on get it get it
where is it all I want is yes no I put
this on the de bris and then I run the
hell away right I can get down to the
sewer right right well put yes run bloom
okay go go go go gotta go now yeah yes
alright alright alright alright okay
okay
now he's banging down the door so let's
just get situated here cuz I wonder what
hours I had been getting close to the
end here hang on I got to see something
yeah maybe I'm gonna see I don't know
wow that's not fair again with the not
fairness of that that's a fair
oh crap ah crap but yeah okay yeah yeah
this is it of right don't litter
what wait a minute whoa whoa wait a
minute
whoa whoa did my game just crash oh it
did oh you son of a [ __ ] it crashed
mother humper what the poo penis
trying it again hopefully knowing that
visual error I don't even know what the
hell that is
that's another bug that needs to be
fixed oh please please please please
yeah
all right sweet yes
yeah all right this is fantastic this is
great all right cool
oh I thought for certain I thought for
sure that I'd be totally bone there I
don't even hear the monster banging on
the door anymore okay so we got the last
area that we need to go through which is
awesome because we're almost done with
this game oh no finish it up one more
part here cuz hopefully I'm gonna be
able to get this so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos and I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye
Janet
No
Oh
Oh God
why did that scare me I have no idea I
just saw a big shadowy figure
I saw